keine schule keine unis italien kämpft
mit drastischen maßnahmen gegen das
corona virus thüringen hat einen neuen
ministerpräsidenten die wahl von bodo
ramelow ist das vorläufige ende der
erfurter regierungskrise gedenken in
hanau familienpolitiker menschen in der
ganzen stadt trauern um die opfer der
rassistischen morde vor zwei wochen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers genannt in allen an
einem sehr ereignisreichen tag wir
bringen sie auf den aktuellen stand
heute um 7 sport nachher in der sendung
mit kristin otto mit fußball dfb-pokal
kunden haben wir müssen beginnen mit dem
kampf gegen das corona virus der
weltweit zu neuen maßnahmen führt gerade
kommen neue meldungen aus italien
dort steigt die zahl der todesfälle seit
tagen guest seit gestern wieder fast 30
mehr insgesamt jetzt 107 menschen die
gestorben sind
die regierung schließt ab morgen alle
schulen und unis es gibt auch zumindest
pläne dass alle öffentlichen
veranstaltungen sowie kino und
theatervorstellungen verboten werden und
wir gehen live nach rom zu andreas
postel andreas guten abend wie geht das
land jetzt damit um das ändert ja doch
einiges für italien
den ganzen nachmittag hat das
italienische kabinett beraten was denn
angemessen sei angesichts der lage aber
was ist schon angemessen in dem land
europas was am stärksten von dem kochen
corona virus von corona virus ausbruch
betroffen ist deswegen ist
ministerpräsident konnte vor einer
halben stunde hier vor die kameras
getreten und hat in der tat angekündigt
dass schulen und universitäten
geschlossen werden ab morgen bis zum 15
märz und zwar landesweit das sind
drastische maßnahmen aber an in
anbetracht der fallzahlen in anbetracht
der vielen toten die es jetzt hier gibt
das betrifft vor allem alte menschen
menschen die geschwächt sind die ein
schwaches immunsystem haben um die zu
schützen müssen eben alle anderen eben
auch ihren beitrag leisten und deswegen
bleiben schulen und kitas und
universitäten geschlossen die eltern
müssen jetzt damit umgehen was passiert
mit dem vater der zur arbeit geht und
seine kinder zu hause lassen muss also
all das sind fragen die werden wir
morgen im laufe des tages sehen das
virus grassiert hier schon seit mitte
februar sagen die experten und weil man
danach sucht was der eigentliche
ursprung ist weshalb gerade in italien
so stark dass wir uns zum ausbruch
gekommen ist sind auch die fallzahlen so
hoch gegangen weil die virologen
natürlich viel testen und bei diesen
tests kommen auch viele infizierte bei
heraus eine gute nachricht gibt es heute
es gibt auch über 200 die wieder genesen
sind und vom kroner virus geheilt sind
sagt andreas postel zdf roben herzlichen
dank und dann diese nachricht heute
israel hat ein faktisches einreiseverbot
erlassen für touristen unter anderem aus
deutschland österreich und frankreich
ausgenommen ist nur wer sich in israel
für 14 tage in häusliche quarantäne
begeben könne die lufthansa lässt viele
flugzeuge am boden weil immer weniger
menschen noch reisen wollen
und auch in deutschland gibt es mehr
infektionen 262 inzwischen tobias häfner
über die lage bei uns fenster auf ein
schneller abstrich im schutzanzug die
probe ab ins labor
das hier wird ab sofort sozusagen einen
drive thru für corona verdachtsfälle in
groß gerau bei darmstadt das auto als
wartezimmer aber kommen darf nur wer vom
gesundheitsamt dazu aufgefordert wird
sind nun ziel des verfahrens war es auch
dass infizierte potenzielle väter
patienten keinerlei kontakt haben zur
praxis oder klinik patienten versorgen
und vorsorgen aber auch ängsten mit
aufklärung und offen ausgesprochenen
wahrheiten entgegentreten das will der
gesundheitsminister
der höhepunkt der ausbreitung ist noch
nicht erreicht
unsere strategie ist weiterhin die
ausbreitung von corona innerhalb
deutschlands und den betroffenen
regionen zu verlangsamen und einzudämmen
ein drängendes problem dabei
schutzausrüstung wird täglich knapper
weil die produktion in china
eingebrochen ist und sich gleichzeitig
fast die ganze welt eindecken will
seit 11 uhr heute gilt nun ein deutsches
exportverbot für schutzmasken zur
deckung des privat bedarfs an
desinfektionsmitteln wollen bund und
länder vorschriften lockern
danach ist es apothekerin und apothekern
möglich desinfektionsmittel zur
händedesinfektion für den privaten
gebrauch auch ob mit industrie alkohol
herzustellen schutz stehe vor
ökonomischen interessen sagt die
regierung und doch werden auch die
folgen für die wirtschaft immer
sichtbarer
die lufthansa-gruppe lässt vorübergehend
gleich 150 jets am boden die nachfrage
nach flügen ist komplett im keller
besonders wichtig ist es alte und kranke
menschen zu schützen also die gefahr
möglichst gering zu halten dass sie mit
dem virus in kontakt kommen
krankenhäuser alten- und pflegeheime
haben die hygiene vorschriften
verschärft wo das virus trotzdem
angekommen ist wird es schwierig eva
schiller und sandra susanka berichten
aus bad rappenau in baden württemberg
besuch vorläufig verboten
120 menschen stehen dem pflegebereich
des bad rappenauer seniorenheims unter
quarantäne
nach seinem italien urlaub hat ein 32
jähriger pfleger seine kollegin und
einen heimbewohner mit dem corona virus
angesteckt die anwohner besorgt war ich
ja nicht was muss ich hier angefangen
hat man geht ja ein kaufe mir schon gut
unterwegs und weiß was noch alles kommt
ich bin selber einem altenpflegeheim
tätig und nehme das schon ernst
der fall zeigt das dilemma der korona
krise strenggenommen nach behörden
empfehlung müssten alle pflegekräfte zu
hause bleiben aber wie soll das gehen
bei 70 pflegebedürftigen
irgendwo muss ja auch die versorgung der
patienten und der bewohner
sichergestellt sein
deswegen hat man eben eine regelung
gefunden das konzept die mitarbeiter
dürfen auch wenn sie in isolation sind
auf direktem weg von ihrer wohnung in
die ins ins heim fahren um dort eben
dann irgendein zu verrichten
ob sich so noch mehr heimbewohner
anstecken ungewiss die drei corona
infizierten wurden in einer klinik
isoliert ihr zustand stabil
aber über allem schwebt noch eine sorge
wir fürchten natürlich dass ältere
infizierte patienten schwerer erkrankt
sein können die das immunsystem ist im
höheren lebensalter schwächer die kraft
des immunsystems lässt nach die
patienten sind generell gefährdet habe
alle heimbewohner und pflegekräfte unter
quarantäne wurden auf das corona virus
getestet die ergebnisse stehen noch aus
weil viele labore überlastet sind
es gibt viele offene fragen immer noch
wenn sie mehr wissen wollen empfehlen
wir ihnen die dokumentation zwischen
pandemie und hysterie wie das corona
virus die welt erschüttert zu sehen
jetzt bei heute de und in der heute app
und im fernsehen heute nacht um zehn
nach 1 unser nächstes thema vorläufiger
schlussstrich nach einem polit geben
thüringen hat einen neuen
ministerpräsidenten
es ist bodo ramelow von der linkspartei
er brauchte drei wahlgänge und dann hat
ihm die einfache mehrheit gereicht
der erste anlauf zur wahl vor fast einem
monat hatte zu einer regierungskrise
geführt mit bundesweiten folgen weil der
fdp kandidat mit stimmen der afg ins amt
gekommen waren über die wahl heute aus
erfurt daniela sonntag insgesamt zwei
wahlen sechs wahlgänge und eine antwort
von bodo ramelow
nehmen sie die ball an die politik krise
in thüringen ist erst einmal beendet der
ex-ministerpräsident ist zurück im amt
zweimal tritt der gegen björn höcker an
im dritten wahlgang reicht die einfache
mehrheit 42 stimmen von rot-rot-grün
demonstrativ verweigert ramelow nach der
wahl böcke einen handschlag und wenn ich
deutlich von nehmen kann dass die
demokratie im vordergrund steht dann bin
ich bereit auch ihn merkel die hand zu
geben aber erst dann wenn sie die
demokratie verteidigen
ramelow will somit den abstimmungs
tricks der afg abrechnen auch hawkings
rückzug im dritten wahlgang heute war
strategie sagt die afg selbst weil man
schon noch die möglichkeit sich offen
halten wollte dass man dass wir die bei
von ministerpräsidenten ramelow daneben
auch anfechten denn er hat ja keine
mehrheit
doch daraus wird wohl nichts es gab mehr
ja als nein stimmen für ramelow
weil die fdp und thomas kemmerich gar
nicht mit wählten und die cdu sich
enthielt lediglich im dritten wahlgang
eine enthaltung weniger ich bin stolz
auf meine fraktion klar ist auch dass
wir jetzt eine situation haben wo es
eine rot rot grüne minderheitsregierung
gibt wir sind als cdu eine konstruktive
opposition wir werden eigenständig
anträge einbringen mit der cdu hat
rot-rot-grün heute das protokoll für den
gemeinsamen plan bis zum nächsten jahr
unterschrieben
ramelow minister sind
thüringen gewinnt heute ein stück
politische normalität zurück und wir
gehen auch mal live nach thüringen
melanie haack ist dort für uns melanie
bodo ramelow ist gewählt er hat aber
nach wie vor keine eigene mehrheit wie
soll denn das regieren in thüringen
jetzt in zukunft ablaufen genau gerade
ist bodo ramelow hier hinter mir in die
staatskanzlei gekommen mit seinen
ministern
es gibt die erste kabinettssitzung und
morgen geht eben das zeitbegrenzte
regieren los am 25 april im nächsten
jahr gibt es neuwahlen und bis dahin hat
man sich ja geeinigt mit der cdu auf den
sogenannten stabilitätsmechanismus man
will projektbezogen zusammenarbeiten
die minderheitsregierung mit der cdu das
heißt man will klare themen durchbringen
gesetze durchbringen den haushalt für
das nächste jahr
auch das thema kommunalfinanzen den
ländlichen raum stärken und lehrer und
polizisten einstellen somit erhofft er
sich dass da die mehrheiten entstehen
und man so erstmal auf die begrenzte
zeit bis nächstes jahr im april hier
regieren kann
melanie herzlichen dank und ein weiteres
wichtiges thema heute die mehr als
10.000 flüchtlinge die aus der türkei
nach griechenland und damit in die eu
wollen
auch heute hat die griechische polizei
tränengas und blendgranaten eingesetzt
damit niemand über die grenze kommt
gleichzeitig krisendiplomatie in ankara
der eu-ratspräsident hat den türkischen
präsidenten getroffen
dieser hatte mit der ankündigung die
grenzen zu öffnen dafür gesorgt dass
tausende migranten zur grenze kamen und
die eu-innenminister suchen jetzt im
moment in brüssel nach einer lösung an
der gehry nec beobachtet dass für uns
angesichts der bilder von der grenze
lässt denn dass die eu zu einer neuen
linie finden
ja aber anders als man meinen könnte es
ist schon bemerkenswert mit welcher
klarheit und härte die 27 eu
innenminister heute die abschottung der
griechischen grenze noch einmal
verteidigt haben es gab keine kritik
daran dass griechenland die
asylverfahren für die nächsten vier
wochen ausgesetzt hat im gegenteil der
deutsche innenminister horst seehofer
sagte wörtlich das sei in ordnung
schließlich verteidigten die griechen
eine europäische außen-
es geht bei dem innenministertreffen
hier in brüssel auch nicht darum
flüchtlinge aus dem niemandsland
zwischen der türkei und griechenland
aufzunehmen denn so heißt es hier
europa werde sich nicht vom türkischen
präsidenten erdogan erpressen lassen und
so bleibt vielleicht nur ein
klitzekleines zeichen der hoffnung für
die flüchtlinge auf den in den
überfüllten lagern auf den griechischen
inseln
denn es will sich unter führung von
horst seehofer vielleicht eine koalition
der willigen zusammenschließen
die möglicherweise kinder und
jugendliche aus diesen lagern übernehmen
würde aber bleiben wir realistisch auch
dafür wird sich vermutlich nur eine
handvoll eu staaten finden anne gellinek
zdf brüssel zu diesem thema dankeschön
und dann gucken heute abend in dieser
sendung auf eine stadt in trauer nach
hanau wo es vor zwei wochen das
rassistisch motivierte attentat gab
jetzt im moment gedenken sie dort der
opfer zu der offiziellen trauerfeier
sind bundespräsident und bundeskanzlerin
gekommen
die tat bei der neuen menschen mit
ausländischen wurzeln starben hatte das
ganze land getroffen
der tatverdächtige ein 43-jähriger
deutscher nahm sich danach das leben
über diesen abend heute in hanau peter
wagner trauer in hanau und neun junge
menschen alle opfer eines rassistischen
mörders trauer aber auch bitterkeit und
zorn sagte bundespräsident weil dieses
verbrechen eine vorgeschichte habe eine
vorgeschichte geistige brandstiftung und
stimmungsmache es ist dieses klima in
dem terroristen zur waffe greifen manche
sich sogar gerechtfertigt fühlen zu
morden
steinmeier appellierte an die demokraten
im land nicht länger zu schweigen und
grundwerte zu verteidigen
das schweigen der vielen darf nicht zur
ermutigung der wenigen dürren nein die
mehrheit muss sich zeigen
die mehrheit muss sich zeigen immer
wieder im verein am stammtisch im
fußballstadion
die mal kitschig ist in hanau geboren
hat wie viele dort seit dem anschlag
angst um seine familie
er kennt es ihm auf europa und findet
bekannt geworden
für seine freunde diese menschen kamen
jeden tag etwas zu kaufen sondern um
hallo zu sagen und mich zum armen oder
ich sie so mahnen jetzt sind die alle
nicht mehr da ich möchte von meiner
seite aus nicht mehr viele genauso die
angehörigen nicht mehr viele wörter
hören sondern wir wollen taten sehen
dass was passiert dass so etwas nie
wieder zustande kommt tausende verfolgen
die trauerfeier draußen auf hanaus
marktplatz hanaus oberbürgermeister
kaminsky fand schon am tag des anschlags
orte voller anteilnahme
heute zeigt er sich kämpferisch und
deshalb sagen wir allen rassisten die
mit ihren parolen unsere stadt unser
land vergiften
wir sind mehr und wir sind stärker als
eure hass für die opfer von hanau wird
es eine gedenkstätte geben ihre namen
sollen niemals in vergessenheit geraten
ganz anderes thema jetzt und damit in
die usa der super tuesday gestern und
die vorwahlen bei den demokraten in 14
bundesstaaten die waren vor allem für
einen super nämlich diesen herrn hier
joe biden der ex-vizepräsident hat so
wie es im moment aussieht in neun
bundesstaaten die meisten delegierten
stimmen gesammelt wichtig für den
parteitag der demokraten im juli sein
schärfster konkurrent ist und bleibt
bernie sanders der nach aktuellem stand
in vier staaten gewann in maine liegen
beide gleichauf
die anderen kandidaten abgeschlagen der
milliardär michael bloomberg warf
daraufhin hin
ines trams jetzt über das was wohl ein
zweikampf werden wird fasst politisch
tot war er nach niederlagen in den
ersten vorwahlen nun ist joe biden
wieder da für viele ist er der kandidat
der donald trump schlagen kann beiden
der die politische spaltung im land und
partei überbrücken will
viele demokraten wollen normalität keine
extreme
wir sind sehr lebendig ruft er
unsere kampagne spiegelt die vielfalt
dieser partei und dieses landes wieder
so muss es sein denn wir müssen jeden
mitnehmen jeden auf kollisionskurs mit
beiden der erklärte demokratischer
sozialist bernie sanders er nicht er
polarisiert will eine politische
revolution den großen staat kalifornien
holt er doch er schneidet schlechter ab
als erwartet
wir werden stammt nicht schlagen mit der
immer segen altenpolitik senders geht
auf konfrontation stiche gegen
kontrahent beiden einer von uns in
diesem rennen hat damals die opposition
gegen den krieg im irak angeführt er
steht für euch ein anderer kandidat hat
für den irakkrieg gestimmt dass geld
keine wahl kaufen kann erfährt
milliardär mike bloomberg eine halbe
milliarde dollar investierte er in
seinen wahlkampf doch er verliert klar
am morgen steigt er aus dem rennen aus
will nun joe biden unterstützen wollen
die demokraten nach links rücken oder in
der mitte bleiben
es sieht aus nach einem zermürbenden
zweikampf zwischen zwei männern
ein kampf von dem donald trump
profitieren könnte
der super tuesday in den usa jetzt kommt
der ins dashboard mit kristin genau
fußball wenn der kleine den großen
gestern abend war mal wieder genau das
zu erleben was im dfb pokal so reizvoll
macht hochgradig emotional der erste fc
saarbrücken erreicht als erster vierte
liga vereinen der geschichte des
wettbewerbs das halbfinale
nach dem triumph im elfmeterschießen
gegen den erstligisten fortuna
düsseldorf dank des überragenden
torwarts das saarland feiert ein
fußballfest sein größtes bisher und im
mittelpunkt steht er daniel barth fünf
elfmeter hat er pariert vier allein im
elfmeterschießen einen zuvor im spiel
unglaublich
mir fällt nichts dazu ein ich bin
eigentlich überhaupt nicht dafür
bekannte erhöhter zweiten mit dem 1 1 in
der 90 minute hatte sich düsseldorf
gerade so in die verlängerung gerettet
episch das elfmeterschießen 20 schützen
insgesamt kein feldspieler der nicht ran
musste und nachdem mario müller als
siebter von 10 sa bürgerschützen
verwandelt hatte machte daniel bax das
halbfinale klar so viele erwachsene
weinende männer hier zu sehen die einige
operationen einige schlachten einige
spiele schon hinter sich haben und dann
mit tränen in den augen sie umarmen zu
dürfen
pokal geschichte die nun erst im finale
da am liebsten gegen die bayern enden
soll
tja alles noch möglich denn der rekord
pokal gewinner aus münchen zieht auch
ins halbfinale einer allerdings längst
nicht so dramatisch
bei den überraschend defensiv
eingestellten schalker erzählt josua
kimmig das tor des abends 10
die bayern seit 14 pflichtspielen ohne
niederlage behalten das triple im visier
ja und die halbfinal auslosung ist dann
am sonntag können wir uns jetzt alle
gemeinsam die lottozahlen anschauen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 14 19 22 29 46
47 und die superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
leider auch keine besonders guten
nachrichten beim wetter der februar war
ja ziemlich nass auch jetzt im märz
immer wieder regen wo es morgen am
heftigsten schüttet sagt gleich katja
horneffer ich empfehle ihnen das heute
journal 21 uhr 45 mit der kollegin
marietta slomka sie hat fragen an bodo
ramelow morgen punkt 19 uhr gibt es uns
wieder vom gesamten team danke für das
interesse und ihnen allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
gab sonnenschein und zum teil auch noch
einige schauer jetzt aber kommt tief
elli und tiefe lief am atlantik bringt
uns viel regen morgen können in
deutschland zum teil bis zu 30 liter
regen pro quadratmeter fallen
und das mit dem regen geht schon in der
zweiten nachthälfte hier im äußersten
westen los im sauerland kann auch etwas
schnee dabei sein und es droht daher
straßenglätte auch dort wo der regen auf
gefrorenen boden fällt denn im osten
sinken die temperaturen bis minus 4 grad
sonst ist es im osten häufig klar in
norddeutschland bildet sich auch mal
nebel und morgens sieht dann der regen
von tiffany weiter in richtung nordosten
schon mittags erreicht er münchen und
bis zum abend dann auch bremen das
altenburger land und den oberpfälzer und
bayerischen wald im nordosten ist es
dagegen zum teil sogar ein bisschen
sonne ich da liegen die temperaturen bei
10 11 grad sonst werden fünf bis acht
grad erreicht und am mildesten wird es
am oberrhein mit zwölf grad und das
liegt daran dass das spätestens zum
abend der wind böig auffrischt da sind
sturmböen ich zum beispiel auf der
schwäbischen alb im schwarzwald und auch
im hunsrück das tief zieht dann am
freitag weiter über norddeutschland
hinweg danach geht es wechselhaft weiter
der sonntag wird freundlicher schöner
abend noch